and let's speak now too the shadow
sector is safe for working pensions
Jonathan Ashworth and and I wonder if we
can start a morning to you by the way we
started being incredibly rude uh let's
start with those those awareness figures
um unemployment creeping up and expected
to continue to go in that direction I
mean that is that would be worrying if
we weren't experiencing you know record
almost historic uh historic lows in that
particular regard well what you've seen
from the statistics which has came out
just first thing this morning is that
you're seeing the real impact now of
both low growth in fact we've gone from
low growth to no growth under the
conservatives you're also seeing the
impact of a problem in your NHS because
we've got the highest numbers out of
work for reasons of sickness probably on
record about two and a half million and
you've got increasing numbers of older
workers have left the labor market so
what you're seeing now is that we unlike
other countries have not recovered our
pre-pandemic employment rates and you're
also seeing wages collapsing because of
the ravages of inflation it's why you
need a plan for growth you need a plan
to reform and rescue and fix your NHS
and you actually need significant
welfare reforms that I've been putting
forward to support people back to work
when you have the inflation running in
double digits I mean there's not an
awful lot you can do to stop to stop
that disability between wage growth and
where inflation is sitting is there
really otherwise otherwise would be
seeing massive pay increases across the
board but that's why you've got to try
and get more people back into back into
work it's where I put forward
significant reforms the way in which our
social security system works to stop
trapping people out of work to deal with
the traps in the social security system
to encourage people back to work but
also to offer people better support that
you had really soon like yesterday
saying everybody should learn maths
until 18 well great if there were the
teachers there but one of the problems
we've got in our labor market is there's
millions of people with poor literacy
poor numeracy not getting any tailored
support from the job centers from the
employment system to help them find good
jobs they're changes I want to bring in
it sounds to me that you you wouldn't be
too far away from Russia sunac and his
desire for a high wage high skill
economy well that's a labor desire we
want High wages we want High skills we
want high growth in fact we've got a big
ambition to grow our economy so it's the
fastest growing economy in the G7 under
Richie sunac we're after 13 years of
conservatives now we've had low growth
we've got low wages people are worse off
people are hard up people can't afford
the basics in life that's what 13 years
of conservative rule gives you let's
talk just briefly if we can about
prepayment meters in terms of energy use
and we have had some movement and from
off gen on this one it's a called it's a
court of practice that the energy
companies are going to agree to it
doesn't go far enough I mean I remember
conversations I had with people in
government not that long ago and the
idea that it would only be banned for
you know disabled people and those over
85. it feels as if they haven't gone
quite as far as they were intending I
mean that I think they're dragging the
hills I think the government of drug
their heels they should have got a grip
of this we know we know that people are
really struggling with energy bills
which have gone through the roof as well
as everything in the shop the weekly
shopping's gone up I mean the price of
everything has gone up and people are
worse off after 13 years of the
conservatives when we're in this type of
Crisis this cost of living crisis the
government should be doing everything
everything to get a grip of these
scandals and the fact that it's still
slow they're dragging their heels it's
just so frustrating for people who are
really strong would labor then legislate
to stop to ban this practice we've got
to take action on this I mean I mean I'm
not enough of a uh a payment meter uh
specialist to know if legislation is
necessarily the right answer in this
particular circumstance but I do know
the government should be getting a grip
of it now um can we talk about the the
elections that are forthcoming and of
course but time is running out for
people if they want to get uh their vote
on ID sorted out certainly today the
last day to get you to get your postal
code done what do you make of these
voter ID reforms I mean the the the line
from the government is pretty
straightforward we don't really have any
opportunity to know exactly how
widespread fraud is in this area every
other country and lots of other
countries Europe do it what is this
we've had all we've had these regulatory
bodies which investigate uh voter fraud
and we've had hardly any had hardly any
whatsoever and the thing that gets me is
I mean I've had this on the doorstep and
I've been knocking on doors why is it if
you're an older person you can use uh
your oyster card your bus pass
but a younger person can't the
government line is that that it requires
more identification to achieve that to
gain up that another person's rail card
than it does that sounds very suspect to
me but but so would the labor party act
to to repeal well I don't think we need
this vote today we've never had this
before
we should be doing everything we can to
increase voter turnout and we'll see
what happens we'll see if voter turnout
drops as a consequence of these of these
changes have been put in place which
which appears to suggest to me that if
we don't see significant terms
we didn't support this no we didn't
support this but I'm asking you would
you repeat it well I think I think in
the legislation there has to be a review
of it so we have to look at that review
but look we're not in favor of this so
I'm sure we will want to take the
measures in place when an expand voter
turnout I mean what is it that you think
is so difficult for people to log on to
a website tap in the National Insurance
number and upload a photo in fact you
don't even need to do that there are
there are countless ways in which you
improve your identity given that so much
of Europe does this I'm just wondering
what the problem I think I think I think
the issue is look you know we we live in
a world where I suspect both you and I
uh are probably pretty comfortable with
using the internet now to apply for
apply for things it is becoming
increasingly difficult I have to say
well that well there you go I mean you
say that in jest but there is a
generation uh not necessarily an age by
the way because perhaps they cannot
afford the 5G associated with their
phone they cannot afford Wi-Fi who are
digitally excluded I mean I get on the
doorstep when I go around my own
Leicester constituency we kind of assume
in Westminster that everyone's got
access to the internet and that
everybody perhaps will be watching this
online they won't be there are so we
don't want to exclude people who have
not got easy access to the internet and
that's the thing that really worries me
I was like how is labor going to how is
labor going to how is labor going to
perform at these set of local elections
we know from the conservative party
chairman that they're expecting to lose
a thousand seats that's why you have to
say that didn't he so he can but he
comes on your show
but what I do know is when I talk to
people across the country they are
really had enough of 13 years of
conservative government where the
economy isn't growing living standards
have collapsed and you cannot get an
appointment with a GP when you want it
the waiting list for the NHS are going
through the roof and getting worse I
mean they're the things that people are
talking about in this election campaign